hi for screen junkies boobie fights Oh
what the heck hi how's it going
everybody movie fights hashtag movie
fights live we are alive and I'd also
like to say hello to hashtag Allen
nation hoot hoot
thanks for tuning in y'all we have a
special oh yeah good stuff we got a
special one-on-one Throwdown today two
of our favorite fighters two awesome
women who are going to collide and movie
thoughts and opinions
oh let's me who shall we what's going on
first off you know her from Collider you
know we're from all over the place I'd
like to welcome to the program imma
fight well thank you very much for
welcoming me hashtag fight flight
hashtag fight flight hashtag buy for
life that's the one Scott mance is
trying to make happen so yeah here we
are
yes is it some different owl I feel like
your Apple got smaller oh you know as
one ages their owl gets smaller
I don't know what that means but no this
is personal Percival is uh yeah just
rooster life for some reason I I
envisioned him more majestic I think
it's maybe just the the majesty ever
meet your heroes always more majestic in
the imagination and Emma you're gonna be
squaring off against someone who brings
a crazy style to movie fights she's
outside the box and on the town
she's the host from that everything's
coming up Simpsons podcast and he's
written a book about the Simpson
basically if you want anything Simpsons
related you're gonna want to consult
Julia Prescott I was trying to be
respectful and didn't want it cut in you
know I guess they know podcast rules but
I wanted to make a crack about how your
owl is your picture of dorian gray where
yeah
holding now we're here oh yeah Phife
life is a really great hashtag over the
notes I had that yeah Chuck I feel like
Prescott press challenges you know Scott
nation house house house Prescott power
okay all right maybe some people will
pick it up now like shopping hit up that
hashtag movie fights live hashtag with a
hashtag idea for Julia Prescott thank
you for being here and I'm really
excited about this matchup cuz you
ladies both have massive movie knowledge
and nerd um but you have vastly
different styles so that's very exciting
equally matched and deciding these
matches this battle these questions the
damn cam what's going on Dan Merle in
the fact zone yes sir
how's it going hey pretty good pretty
good yeah just excited for another movie
fight yeah and we have the fantastic
Danielle Radford hello-o social media
consultant and III remarked earlier your
whole ensemble is I don't know very well
coordinated yeah it is
working today big time not that it
doesn't work normal okay it's a write
more now hell yeah and you know you are
the voice of the people do you want to
tell these folks how that works okay so
the way that this is going to work is
you will see a pull in the upper right
hand corner of your screen there are
lots of really fun pulls on Twitter that
this one is the only one that counts is
the one that is on YouTube if you have
any questions about how that works check
in the description bug someone in the
chat tons of people are there to answer
your questions but in the case of a tie
we go to the fan polls and those will
help us break those ties so get active
in there we'll let you know when the
polls go up typically after first
arguments because we want to make sure
it's about the arguments second go on to
the hashtag movie fights live because if
I see anything interesting any a dank
memes as how likes to put them I will be
shouting you out on the show very cool
Thank You Danielle and before we launch
into our competitive movie jibber-jabber
Dan Morrell has some thoughts an
announcement for
yeah how you know if there's one thing
I've learned through six-and-a-half
years working years screen junkies and
fandom is that the internet loves change
[Laughter]
so yeah we this is something we've been
talking about for a very long time and
is actually been in the process for a
lot of months but we are always in the
office and with our expanding team and
it's gotten bigger over the last year so
what you're super happy about we're
always looking at the channels and we're
always thinking about what keeps us
fresh what is gonna keep keep us pumping
out what what we want to pump out what
we're excited about doing and one thing
that we've looked at a lot over the last
year so really since you know we
revamped the show and everyone loved it
without the chairs but we decided to
bring the chairs back because that was
what we wanted but we're always looking
at things and it's hard to believe this
but movie fights will be in October
we've been doing the show for five years
that's which is crazy over 225 episodes
with hand nuts and what's something that
we always keep hitting up against is a
few things number one when you do the
show for this long it's harder to find
questions that you haven't done before
yeah because there's like 12 weeks a
year where there's like a huge movie
where you have you know what you're
doing and then you're filling the other
forty was like what do we do and as you
do it for many years you start running
out of some of those yeah secondly as
partially evidenced today is we have so
many awesome people that come and do the
show but the problem with working with
awesome people is that other people find
out they're awesome and then they get
busy doing other stuff so we love our
two guests today but we had a third
guest who couldn't make it today because
he's awesome he's awesome to get pulled
away and this has been kind of a
recurring thing for the last really
years yeah so what we decided to do is
movie fights is not going away
it will never go away but we were
looking at both fandom entertainment
which used to be screen junkies news and
this channel and what we decided to do
was to take this show and we're gonna
start doing it basically when we want to
it's what we it's what we did with the
screen junkies show not
long ago which is when we have something
that we want to do when we have
something that we are really passionate
about we're gonna do it it's gonna be on
this channel but we're also gonna make
the chain so the movie fights is not
going to be a weekly show anymore we're
actually going to move honest trailer
commentaries and this is something that
we've thought of doing since we started
doing the show we're moving on a show of
commentaries from the Phantom
entertainment channel to the screen
junkies channel that will be our
Thursday upload and then the weekends as
it has been for a long time now it's
gonna cycle through a bunch of different
stuff that we love to do one of those is
movie fights another one is the screen
junkies show and we really do think that
this is what keeps us excited about the
show it's what keeps the show fresh it's
what we hope keeps the show relevant and
meaningful and tied to the stuff that we
really want to talk about but honestly
the week to week struggle of making the
show because all of us also have a bunch
of other stuff that we put on our plates
in the last four and a half years this
frees us up to work on a lot of stuff
that we are really super passionate
about and we don't want this show to
suffer because it's harder to do
questions and because everybody's had
stuff added onto their plates so that's
the move that we're gonna make obviously
any time there's a move like this the
first thing that everyone points to
because we're part of fandom now is
everyone says like your overlords have
given you your orders that this is 100%
not true the thing that we always try to
do here on the show is to be honest with
you because we wouldn't be here without
you
this is 100% a move that we collectively
sat down in a room as a group and
thought about and agonized over because
we know that there's so many people that
love watching the show every week and
it's a big part of their week and we
don't take that lightly which is why
we're committed to making sure that you
know that the show is still going to be
a big part of screen junkies we just
honestly feel that this is the way to
keep the show fresh to keep the channel
fresh and to rotate in some stuff that
we think people are really like so
that's what's happening with movie
fights now that's not gonna happen right
away Danielle tell us well first of all
Danielle can tell us about going forward
some of the things you can
to still see from movie fights and then
how has got all the info on how we're
gonna end the weekly phase of the show
so we're still gonna be at comic-con do
not even worry about that we're still
doing our comic-con we're still gonna do
the stuff that you love wouldn't that we
do when rising the sky Walker comes out
we're gonna be doing a Star Wars fight
when the Joker comes out we're gonna do
a Joker fight we're gonna light dance
said we know we're gonna keep these two
about once a month but we're also can't
nobody tell us when the movie fight if
something big happens in entertainment
news and movie news and we want a movie
fight about it we don't movie byte about
it that's all there is to it yeah yeah
every every movie fights thing that we
do that you like recurring best of the
summer the year everything we're still
gonna do it but how has the info on how
the I'm very nervous about the wait
yeah well Dan you should be nervous
because you're going through the
gauntlet but that hasn't stopped you
before so what we're gonna do we're
gonna bring the weekly movie fights to
an end in grand style Dan Merle the
longest title belt holder in movie
fights history it will be facing
one-on-one many of his toughest
challengers many of us most bitter
challengers who are like so and we will
see if Dan can get through that gauntlet
a treacherous journey indeed still
holding the title then on July 4th to
celebrate America's birthday Yankee
Doodle Dandy we're going to have a last
fighter standing tournament so maybe Dan
will be putting that belt on the line
still maybe Dan will be competing to
regain the belt so it's gonna be an
awesome run up and yeah you know what
I'll miss doing it every week but I'll
still enjoy being uh being a part of the
fun and you know I've been with screen
junkies just like Dan has for six and a
half years and
yeah there's been a few changes so yeah
you go with the flow and this isn't to
say that I don't love doing the show and
oh my gosh I appreciate all you guys
tuning in every week and getting to work
with just one of the smartest moving
Minds Dan Morrell one of the smartest
funniest most personable individuals I
know Daniel Radford and everybody that
puts the show together so we're excited
to keep bringing it to you
just a little bit less and to my mom
who's probably watching this you know
what to fill the movie fights time every
week I will FaceTime you we'll go from
there
um so that's basically it I hope you
keep tuning in and this run up and keep
tuning in whenever it's on and yeah
watching all the content from screen
junkies and fandom and yeah enough of
this jibber-jabber he dropped that
package
[Music]
hey thanks door okay so this one-on-one
matchup against all right lads opening
this week and I wonder how it's gonna do
at the box office Dan I'll ask you about
that at the end of the show Aladin opens
this weekend so we asked who what is the
all-time greatest Disney animated
musical the all-time er this is a hard
question we want to do okay we're gonna
do it on the docket yes so we're gonna
do it all right best Disney animated
musical ever let's start with Emma all
right
so let's get into a little bit of Disney
history here so Disney and the late 80s
early 90s was going through a
renaissance it began with the Little
Mermaid the first three films the last
of which was Aladdin again the
live-action adaptation of which is
opening in theaters this weekend but the
best Disney animated musical of all time
was the one that came right in the
middle and that is 1991's Beauty and the
Beast not to be confused with the
live-action version of Beauty and the
Beast though part of my argument is that
because the music of Beauty and the
Beast was so great it's part of the
reason why the 2017 live-action version
was so disappointing is because it does
have these incredible melodies that we
know and love and they brought in all
these people who couldn't really sing to
try and do them justice and they did not
Beauty and the Beast let's talk about
some of the awards that it won it won
Best Original Score Best Original Song
it was nominated for Best Picture and it
was the first time an animated feature
had ever been nominated picture for Best
Picture and the last time an animated
feature was nominated for Best Picture
before they expanded the nomination pool
to be ten films instead of the original
five six I can't remember it was also
the first musical in 12 years to receive
a nomination for Best Picture and it
remains tied with wall-e for the most
nominated Best Picture animated the most
decorated in terms of Oscar nominations
animated films there we go I can talk
tied with wall-e at six nominations
Beauty and the Beast is this just
beautiful fairy tale it's this very
timeless story that is about people who
are overcoming their prejudices both on
the part of Belle and on the part of the
Beast it has all of the components that
go into making up a great musical it has
got big sweeping ensemble numbers
beautiful power
let's love story everything is great
beating the beast best Disney animated
musical of all time
all right Angela landsbury tale as old
as time Julia what do you got I just
want to say up top then I feel lied to I
feel like you did a move on me that you
don't prepare ha ha and now I feel like
I'm just way in and say yeah Emma that
did not seem purely off the dose and I
just wrote down the okay let's see Tim
writes and [ __ ] Elton John wrote the
songs for this [ __ ] terrorized Cobra
oh wow says he knows work Jost of the
amazing technicolor freakin Dreamcoat
Jesus Christ Superstar Evita these are
places that are just constantly
performed on stages all over the world
because he is a national treasure about
something that I want to focus on that I
feel like your explanation quite is the
music itself okay which songs from
buting the peace and be honest with
yourself look into the mirror right now
look into the depths of your soul be
honest which songs from Beauty and the
Beast [ __ ] slap because none of them
do but you know what does freaking
circle of life I just can't wait to be
king even be prepared
who could forget that drum line so fun
Hakuna Matata that became something that
we all discuss in our everyday lives
after the Lion King came out I want to
tell a story I want to tell stories
about a six-year-old named Julia
Prescott okay oh maybe I was eight
I'm not sure I was at YMCA after school
daycare and the only thing that I have
at him as a bargaining chip to get in
with the cool kids was a cassette tape
of The Lion King soundtrack all right
and I played that on the YMCA
after-school daycare boom box every
single day until I kind of had friends
and I just want to say that the power of
the
The Lion King is the reason why I'm
sitting at this desk today because it is
the songs are still catchy there's I
didn't even get into I mean I know that
there's been a Broadway productions of
both of these movies but I want to talk
about how let's let's open it up great
fight speaking of the fact that there
are Broadway productions of both of
these movies Beauty and the Beast was
the first Disney film that was adapted
into a stage musical and remains the
best of all of their stage musicals
because it is very simple and true to
its musical roots here's the thing is
again Beauty and the Beast already had
all of the components in place you've
got this great ensemble number that
opens up the film Belle with all the
townspeople and Belle's saying and
they're at odds with each other and
through the course of that song we are
introduced to the very concept of this
of this film these songs within beauty
of these helped to propel the story
forward also again totally totally
subjective in terms of what you remember
from the film's I would argue that be
our guest is a real standout from Beauty
and the Beast
Gaston that's why I was notified I was
notified we've reached our f-bomb I see
what you're saying that the opening song
is good but okay let's talk about what
bleeds into everyday pop culture how
many times have you heard that Belle
song be referenced in another TV show or
movie how many times have you heard nah
Sabine yeah how many times you've been
my friend since so many TV and movies I
I'm telling you that everyone's seen the
great parody beauty in the beat about
the Bujji Belle that lives in the Hun is
it
is the first Disney Broadway adaptation
okay that's fine
being the first is all good and whatever
but the Lion King one so many freaking
Tony's it won the Tony Award for Best
Musical Best Musical that's like imagine
going to the Oscars and having a Pixar
film win Best Picture Clause not gonna
happen and won the Tony Award for Best
seen is design best costume design best
lighting the scientists choreography
best direction on a musical and it's
responsible for Julie Taylor's career
the puppetry alone amazing absolutely
and I believe that the production of The
Lion King is absolutely spectacular and
that is what makes the Broadway show
great the thing about Beauty and the
Beast that makes it great is just truly
a good musical I actually would argue
that if the Lion King were not a musical
and I'm not saying any knock against the
Broadway show the stage show winding
because it really is fantastic Broadway
fighters however I do feel that if the
Lion King had not been this like Julie
Taymor rigmarole then the rest of the
Disney probably shows might have been
better because they would have just been
like you know what let's make a show
instead of let's put mermaids on Healy's
which is what they did at the Little
Mermaid musical which is very
unfortunate
okay so again beauty of the beast when
when I think of a that is a very good
musical again you want to have your
stories you want to have your songs they
tried the story forward you have music
that is motivated by a place of emotion
like we get with Belle when she it's
frustrated after Gaston comes to her
house and is like yo let's get married
and she's like I don't think so and that
and you have this great musical theme
throughout and and you know it all kind
of culminates in a great battle at the
end anytime that you have a place where
you can see how how this musical again
it doesn't necessarily have to be able
to be adapted for the stage but that was
the thing about beauty of the beast was
watching it you were like this this is a
great musical okay so I agree with your
definition of a good musical should be
that all the songs feel organic coming
from the character and progress like
they should start at a certain place
story-wise emotionally and ended it
different lace I feel like we still get
that with the Lion King but now I want
to talk about the horny level between
beauty and beast and ranking
okay how many young girls had their
sexual awakening to the Beast
none how many young girls had their
sexual awakening two young simple
literally all of them all of them
it was either young Simba or I think it
was the Fox Robin Hood we're talking
about we're arguing our tits it's not
objective but if we're gonna compare
apples to oranges linking and Beauty and
the Beast I'm gonna go why King because
it's more fun and I feel like it's more
vibrant of a story it's based on
Shakespeare so you got a little bit of
that too it's got Whoopi Goldberg in it
I enjoy that beauty in the piece yes
it's true to this fairy tale set up true
to the fairy tale Sensibility but it's
boring I think and archaic in that way
and I just don't think of many songs for
muting the Beast in my everyday life
that slap I just feel like the way they
wrote the songs for the lighting
they were catchy and they got the job
done musical has 10 songs that slap
necessarily we're talking about the
music we're talking about things that
get stuck in our head and leave us with
a good feeling and I just don't feel
like the Gaston song is something that
I'm gonna be thinking about years later
Emma hit us with those final thoughts
all right so here are my final thoughts
is Beauty and the Beast not only did it
take this classic fairytale format it
expanded upon it it actually was an
interesting take on the fairy tale where
it crafted Belle Beauty the main
character as this smart outsider and
it's ultimately the story about these
two Outsiders who are at odds with each
other and realize that at the end of the
day they have a lot in common and
through the course of it there's a
beautiful sweeping score that carries us
through out all of the household objects
say we had a great musical number and be
our guest and it all ends with a great
happily ever after an arousing reprise
of Angela Lansbury's classic Beauty and
the Beast all right okay yeah I wanna
say a couple things I mentioned that it
was the fourth best-selling album the
arm the Billboard 200 and the
top-selling soundtrack it is the only
soundtrack for an animated film to be
certified diamond nuts ten times
platinum and I
wanted to say that years after the movie
came out at Disneyland they had or maybe
the same year they had a Lion King
parade and it was about a hundred plus
degrees that day and they had guys in
like these monkey costumes that were
swinging on little ropes and there's a
great story where it was like opening
day Michael Eisner was there with like a
whole bunch of other Disney execs and
one of the guys in the dancing monkey
suits you know where this is going he
passed out on line and so they had to
poke him in the middle of this whole
deal and celebration and you know what
you don't get like that with the baby
later it's a story that my mom and I
enjoy and I think he will two-time all
right wow what a passionate throwdown
good stuff both of y'all this is a
toughy Dan what we got in fact I learned
so much today in the course of that
round right yes the old Oscar format
allowed for five for many years until
after the dark night was not nominated
then expanded to allow for up to ten
buting the beast was also nominated for
Oscars for Best Sound and for two of its
other songs Bell and be our guest which
it did not win because it lost two we
saw communities The Lion King one those
same two Oscars for Best Original Score
and Best Original Song there are three
total films to the been nominated for
best animated films that but knighted
for Best Picture beating the Beast is
one of them up and Toy Story or the
other two they were nominated in
consecutive years amongst the the group
of 10 films for best app for Best
Picture but there's not been another
animated film since Toy Story dream the
Best Picture race and yes Beauty the
Beast won one Tony for best costume
design the Lion King won six including
Best Musical so the data facts stand up
thank you guys thank you for
fact-checking
Wow you guys made this super hard
because it was just trading blows your
opening salvo was filled with awards and
great songs and then Julia you came in
with a passion
how it made you friends Ozzy music so
there's man it's like the unstoppable
force versus the immovable object here
it really it it's really difficult but
at the end going with greatest Disney
animated musical and Julia you really
well at first you leaned into the the
Broadway stuff which wasn't doing you
any favors Lion King is just handsome
least age right Julie Taymor right but
there's nothing to do with what we're
talking about here so but then you
started just talking about just how much
those songs slap how many bangers are in
Lion King and it is wall backers and
that that combined with your personal
passion for the project just barely
as now just you're you're you're
truthful cogent argument about the
awards and also there's a lot going for
it but you pushed it over the line with
your personal story so I'm going one for
Lion King Dan I would have loved to have
bought on this one where I would have
answered Pinocchio and just gotten
swatters YES on the passion scorecard as
I'm doing my Julia wins the passion
scorecard going yeah
however I thought that Emma's argument
was a little more focused because while
the Tonys and then the these heart
people passing out are ancillary to what
we're speaking on right which I
appreciate
it was wonderful it was a very good I
felt on Bullock if we're talking about
the movies which it is it's a movie
fights on bulk I felt that Emma's
argument was a little more focused on
the film Beauty and the Beast and why it
uh stood above the film The Lion King
and for those reasons my vote goes with
Emma right on one one we go to the polls
all right as of right now 73% of the
vote from Lion King 26% of the vote for
Beauty and the Beast I did have to
explain to Dan that the Fox in in Robin
Hood is a real thing got tons of tweets
talking about how it's a thing it's yeah
for me it was a Bugs Bunny dressed as a
little sorry for that phrase okay Julia
Wan Emma looking to get on the board
that was good stuff let's go to question
number two be downhill from here we
shall see bright Bern reimagines
Superman as a horror movie villain so we
asked you what other comic book
superhero should get a horror themed
reboot yeah juanzi a spooky take on a
superhero
question 2 we'll start with player 2
Julia my answer to this question is of
course Wonder Woman because really any
woman fronted comic book superhero movie
is a horror movie because life is a
woman is a real living terror and I
think that a reimagining of this as a
horror movie could be really interesting
because you kind of have the time-travel
factor to it
so she can go and like you know get back
on the men that have objectified her and
have belittled her in many different
interesting ways
you could also go back to our home land
and have some fun you know kind of stuff
there and that's about as far as an
argument it's all go right now okay save
out a little bit for later Thank You
Emma
okay listen there are a lot of different
tapes on the horror genre but what is
more terrifying I ask you than the
America that we are living in today
so my pitch is recasting Captain America
not so much as Captain America as he is
make captain make America great again
this cast Captain America as the villain
in a dystopian fictions sort of horror
film wherein it's sort of like a little
bit of like Handmaid's Tale with an edge
of the purge involved and Captain
America isn't the hero he certainly
thinks that he is the hero in his own
mind but he is going around doing things
like taking away women's rights cuz as
you say it is horrifying to be a woman
he is going around trying to you know
keep people out of our borders he is the
embodiment of everything that certain
members of the administration are trying
to make America today and is about the
people trying to survive in that kind of
America and raising up against this
Captain America who is a villain who
again is very much in his own head and
believing that he is in the right and
that by going back to fundamentalism we
are truly perfect protecting everything
that is America
all right ripped from the headlines
Captain America we have Marvel vs. DC
and reimagine as horror movies because I
honestly feel like both of our films
could cause I honestly feel like yeah or
Wonder Woman and your guy could like
pair up and we could just you know sort
of like burn every wall don't worry
every bad guy
there's a potential I think in this in
this make America great again story
because it's like how does Captain
America become this character is he just
I think that it is he basically like
snaps and he's so infected with these
ideas that America is pushing forward
and we would start at a point that like
America is already there we're already
at a point where it's starting to look
more and more like Gilead and handmade
Stalin people are are basically living
with this person who is supposed to be a
symbol of freedom but actually all he is
doing is suppressing people's freedoms
and then you end up having people have
to you know rise up against him but it's
things where it's like oh if you have an
idea that is different from the American
government then Captain America is gonna
come in and he's gonna murder you
because dissent is bad right right right
the only thing that I feel like that
would sway me away okay your argument is
that you know we want to go to movies as
escapism and to be such a clear mirror
to our living everyday hell I feel like
people are going to be turned away from
that I feel like with also Wonder Woman
being reimagined as this horror it kind
of you know that sympathetic villian
that you see kind of in Maleficent is
something that I think could be really
going for her in a way that right you
know you see her kind of taking us
against her oppressor is sure and the
way that it gets down if the [ __ ] is
just the graphic nature okay almost saw
style she you know the really crushes
the same people that are like telling
her that she can only you know earn 73
cents on a dollar to a man or things
like that so we did submit a chokehold
be free burst their head open like that
frame gory horror on her point of view
and shrinkage can be kind of blanket
daenerys targaryen burning down yeah
absolutely any would incite rage on the
internet was definitely way I mean I I
mean I want to talk about inciting rage
on the internet I'm talking about
casting everybody's hero Captain America
they're their symbol of hope and
goodness as the ultimate villain which I
think in of itself is terrifying I don't
think that you're wrong about people
wanting to go to the movies for escapism
however we are talking about creating a
horror film and the best kind of horror
films are horror films that do again
have some sort of basis in reality
around the things that are happening
right now in the stuff that really
terrifies us which is that this could
become
on reality right but if it's so I mean I
I get that as Captain America and you're
going to be dealing with like these
American ideals in these American issues
that are currently plaguing us but it
feels like a similar way in which like
late night hosts are kind of getting
tired about making Trump jokes I just
feel like it's just sort of mine from
that of like these sort of American isms
that are you know leading towards
enchantment as like you know the current
society that there's going to be sort of
a fatigue to that and it's not going to
feel really fresh when you're sitting in
the movie theater watching this horror
movie of what is essentially our daily
life whereas with Wonder Woman I feel
like you know there could be a lot of
really interesting out then with the
time travel that she can sort of go
around to different you know societies
different times and sort of you know
like be able to slip in undetected
because she's a woman and they an
unsuspecting and then she can you know
go through all of these gruesome deaths
and you know get really really gory in
that way and really you know terrifying
and almost a Walter White kind of way
that you don't see crime right but I do
also think in terms of the kind of like
sneaking and undetected if you kind of
frame Captain America as at the start of
it like oh he's this he's this great guy
he's the everyman he is that guy that
that you trust and you believe in and
then you start with that betrayal I
understand what you're saying about it
like not necessarily being the most
fresh and original ideas because it is
something that we are living with on the
daily however again I'm talking about
taking it to an extreme of again sort of
that that like Gilead Handmaid's Tale
kind of place where everybody is super
oppressed by the exact person who they
thought was going to be their Savior
that to me is pretty terrifying but I
don't really see that as horror you know
I just see that as sort of this sort of
like psychological I think that
psychological terror falls within the
horror genre and on top of that I mean
you talk about having things like super
gruesome deaths that is definitely on
the table for this as well you know
you're talking about you know bringing
in some elements of things like the
purge where it's like okay we're all
gonna like we all are now allowed to
commit as many crimes as we want and and
and have it be again very dark and
violent and it and it can come from a
place again of that that very sort of
horrifying just position of having this
like all Americana like bright
everything's great and then you know
having people have their heads chopped
off or exploded but that whatever goes
to my next point with the existence of
the courage and with the existence of
movies like assassination nation and
tragedy girls like at what point our
audience is going to be fatiguing I
think that they already are they don't
want to go and sit and and see you know
they sort of switch on like this
mechanism that they have prescribed to
in the past sure but I think also that
you know with the Wonder Woman take I'm
still not entirely clear on what it is
other than like she's a woman who is
taking revenge right so it's not that
political in the same way God just like
sort of a Jack the Ripper type figure of
somebody who has sort of enraged
it's and the last straw kind of going in
and seeking revenge in a way that's
really fun and exciting and poppy kind
of like a quant aren t know moving okay
I see what you're saying Julia go ahead
and roll this into your final thoughts
now I think I pretty much said
everything that I need to say thank you
you know flipping the American Dream on
its head and just having a very dark
story painted under the guise of
something that looks like it is very
pretty and wholesome and challenging the
the direction that you know things could
go if people don't start actually
stepping up to the plate and flipping
the ID on its head of the person who you
thought was gonna step up to the plate
and be there is actually the person who
is bringing you down all right Wow time
Dan you know our audience loves it when
we get political
but thoughtful passionate arguments from
these ladies Dan take us to the fact
zone and then go ahead and give us your
thoughts on this question yeah I mean
factually it's not really I mean their
pitches so not really much to correct
there as for my pick it's yeah these
were both very unconventional pitches
for the horror genre the twist on the
genre I was really um I was really kind
of split if I'm being honest going into
it but toward the end I think Julia
actually at the very enclosed me a
little bit she put her in a little bit
sharper focus that the Captain America
thing like I definitely see the horror
of the concept but as far as a horror
movie the idea of this sort of bloody
revenge thing that that in my mind kind
of gelled it is more being something
that would find in the horror genre then
the Captain America one which seemed
like almost like a hybrid or I wasn't
quite sure just just as a horror film I
think Julia's pitch sold me more so I'm
going with Julia so it's a 1 for Julia
yeah I actually saw a little bit
differently III felt like Emma's idea
was a little more fully formed and I
thought the touchstone of the purge what
brought it in full
topical relief and then additionally The
Handmaid's Tale so having these genre
shows and movies to give me an idea I
had a clearer picture of what you were
talking about and the purge is a horror
franchise that you resonated there
whereas yeah with Julia I
I had the violent revenge tale but I
wasn't quite seeing as much you know
that could be a violent action movie I
wasn't quite see where like a Tarantino
kind of faster pussycat kill kill kind
of vibe to it
my points damage
what you're going for right yeah so uh
the Internet's gonna be on your side
it's 1:1 let's go to the pole all right
so as of now with 64% of the vote
Captain America will need a percent of
the vote for Wonder Woman hey I've got
things that were put a lot of people
want Batman to be real bad but that
checks out that tracks one that I really
liked that I didn't hear a lot of road
Raider 3 on Twitter said we've tried
them so many times so screw it
how about a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
body horror film
I like that oh yeah josh trank oh right
that was fantastic for and he could have
pulled it off if they hadn't guessed at
the end of that movie I agreed there was
there something there that yeah the
colossal battle at the end not so
colossal all right so it's 1:1 and we're
tied great moment and sports going to
question number three so we got our
first trailer for the new Downton Abbey
movie the other day we asked what TV
show that's no longer airing new
episodes should get a feature-length
follow up a lot Downton Abbey and also
devil it in their Deadwood if you're
looking forward to Deadwood man that's
some good stuff can't wait for that okay
what TV show that's no longer airing new
episodes should get a feature-length
follow up listen I think that a lot of
people when they approach a question
like this they automatically want to go
to something that was canceled that
maybe didn't get its day but Downton
Abbey went out on a high note
and so I'm going to suggest a series
that also went out on a high note that I
honestly wouldn't even suggest if it
weren't for its fantastic follow up
series that takes place way way in the
future and that is Avatar The Last
Airbender this was a Nickelodeon series
that was incredibly well received by
critics and fans alike it is the story
of Aang and how he becomes the avatar
after they think that the avatar has
disappeared for forever he is the last
airbender in the world and it has an
incredibly satisfying ending where they
more or less wrap up all of the loose
ends except that we are also left with
egg being able to achieve the Avatar
state and we know from Legend of Korra
which is the follow-up series that he
did go on to be a great leader in the
eyes of the people however his children
who are adults in Legend of Korra
wouldn't necessarily agree with all of
that so what I want to see is a series
it was a film that covers some of that
time period in between others a lot of
story covered in some of the graphic
novels and things that take place in
between the two series but not so much
that focuses on Aang as an adult and
that is what I think I would like to
the other thing in the gap between
avatar and korra that happens is there
is a huge industrial revolution which is
something that would be very fun to
explore within a feature film alright
Avatar The Last Airbender Julia what do
you got real quick
wasn't there a live-action full-length
movie is directed by M night Shyamalan
choosers my pick for this is the TV show
smash y'all remember smash no you don't
but I do and then a group of people on
the internet do as well smash was a cult
it it was only airing on NBC for two
seasons and it is one of the most
baffling TV experiences I've ever had it
actually gave me friends as well maybe
there's a theme here little things that
I'm choosing I found a group of women
online and some men who are also a
fellow musical theater lovers and we all
found each other it was like you know
reuniting years after theater camp we
found each other and and and we bonded
over this show if you don't know smash
let me give you a quick refresher season
one oh we was directed by Theresa Rebeck
who is a playwright and should not be
running television which is why she got
extracted from that role after season
one and then reinstituted with another
showrunner but the reason why season one
was so great was because of her because
she was kind of building the bridge that
she was standing on there were full plot
lines like the some of the main
characters were trying to adopt a child
and they spent like four episodes on it
and then they just forgot about it and
then wrapped up the first season
regarless smash that makes it so great
is that it was a produced by Steven
Spielberg and a bunch of other people
and Angelica Houston was in it and in
all these great people katharine mcphee
Megan Hilty was in it it was her first
TV starring role and she is from the
Broadway stage and she really killed it
so it's about this production of a
fictional Marilyn Monroe musical and you
know it's all set up where you know
you've got katharine McPhee and main
healthy are these two characters that
are vying for the lead role of Marilyn
and there are all these interviews
before smash originally aired about how
like yeah we're gonna do this show and
then it's going to be a massive hit and
then we're going to get the funding to
make this Marilyn music
on actual Broadway and it's going to be
this amazing crossover then and it
didn't happen because nobody watched
smash and it's amazing but the thing is
smash did find its audience and so this
is my suggestion for what should happen
to smash because the first season was so
delicious TV it was just like you know
the way that people talk about the show
about The Bachelor that's on a bachelor
it's the scripted version the one that
Ken Marino is in burning low no no that
is not it
dang it I'm gonna remember this later
but in what a Peabody um so I feel like
in that same genre smash should be like
a lifetime original movie which is a
lifetime I feel like the full links mesh
give the audience what you promised
before smash originally aired give us
the full Marilyn musical let's open it
up okay okay so I'm hearing you with the
lifetime original movie that's sound
like a great lifetime original movie but
what I'm suggesting here is is an epic
exploration of this really beautifully
crafted world in this time period of
history that isn't necessarily super
addressed and I am proposing it be an
animated film because the series is
animated history of revolution is what
you're talking about that's something
that's not a bit addressed yes a
steampunk doesn't qualify that as being
a pop cultural moment it's definitely a
pop cultural moment yeah yeah no I'm not
saying that it's not a pop culture
definitely a popular thing I'm just
saying that within the world of Avatar
they haven't really addressed how we got
there and for me ultimately that is
secondary that is just going to be
background decoration in this film which
is ultimately going to be about Aang as
an adult as a leader and the way that
the public views in versus the way that
he deals with his children his eldest
child is not a bender and that's like a
big you know sticking point for him or
basically at the end of Avatar he and
Korra are in he and Katara end up
together and you know that they go on to
have children because their adult
children are in Legend of Korra however
we do find out that there definitely was
some tension between them and their
death I'm not suggesting that Aang went
like you know full old man Luke last
last jet
starwars here but I'm saying that I
think there is an interesting story to
explore there of a man who is becoming a
leader who is who is a leader and a
figurehead in the eyes of the people but
is maybe having some struggles with his
family so you're suggesting basically
like it's not quite a prequel it's not
quite a sequel no it actually lives in
between two different series okay but
the thing that I'm pitching I mean I
think that that would be great are you
thinking theatrical release he's out
totally serious I want the budget for a
theatrical release I love that animation
to be beautiful well good luck with
getting that in this day and age when
everything's a Netflix movie I want to
say that because it's an in-betweener
then there have been some questions that
have been answered with The Legend of
Korra
the thing that I'm pitching is that
there are so many questions within the
world of smash that have not been
answered including I just want to see
the Marilyn Musical we never saw the
Marilyn Musical we've seen so many
different numbers of it and people love
it and there was only one night one
night let me tell you story really quick
okay I went to New York one time and I
weaseled my way into getting a media
pass for a one-night-only performance of
bombshell the miracle that never
actually got staged and it was for
charity and I did not get in there
because I don't know if they were really
messy with it and so I ended up just
spending three hours bonding with other
New York paparazzi you got real close by
I flew all the way to New York just to
Tracy's and I know if there are so many
other Smash fans that would do the same
exact thing and when I tell them this
they go crazy so I think that there
would be a whole community people that
would love love love seeing a smash
fully full-length feature film and in a
way that they can access it on lifetime
with the streaming app let's make this
your final thoughts go ahead and add
anything you're talking about the
marketability of a smash musical of a
smash movie avatar the last banner is
Eric bender is pretty universally loved
again by it has a huge fan base that's
got a huge hugely positive critical
reception on top of that it has spawned
a bunch of different you know graphic
and and whatnot that explore the rest of
the world but what I'm saying is that
you brought up the idea of okay this is
kind of an in-between so some of those
questions have been addressed actually
what I'm proposing is that none of those
questions would have existed if it
weren't for the information that we are
inferring from Legend of Korra and
here's the thing guys I just want to see
socket on camera again all right
he seems to be dead in Legend of Korra
and they don't ever really talk about it
he's just gone so give me some sock on
the big screen and that's my final
argument Julie anything else to add I
just want to see them do let's be bad
again I wanna see Megan Hilty in a
flapper costume I want to see I want to
see them actually answer the questions
that they posed in season one and here's
something else that happened between
season one and season two because this
is what happens with TV when they get to
different show runners the second shot
does not care about what the first
showrunner was doing okay so you get the
sort of disjointed like divorced home of
different stories that never get
addressed and I feel like in ten you get
a third showrunner and I'm proposing
that it's me okay and then you I'm gonna
do this like Murder Squad style with
like all the strings attached to all the
plot holes and I'm going to fix all the
plat holes okay and I'm gonna get them
on that stage another one's gonna love
it and we're gonna win another Peabody
for lifetime show was unreal I couldn't
remember the show that was about The
Bachelor it's called a mile oh sorry Dan
did you find that fact in the fact zone
so well I don't know I'm not a bachelor
Peabody and that didn't anything else
factually to do a year not that I can
think of Sheree I'm will be I was the
girl from Roswell but then I remembered
her name gotcha
so so if you ask me going in what would
I be more interested in exploring it's
the the one I've actually seen episodes
of be the avatar last airbender
but the to go with the question what
should get a feature-length follow-up I
have to say Julia made the stronger case
for me having never realized what they
were in the works for throughout the
course of the show we need to see that
Marilyn Musical come to fruition
yeah so I gots to go Julia on this one
dan I hadn't
sorry Internet I've not seen either
that's every seen an episode of Avatar
The Last Airbender noir smash so I don't
come in with any notions as far as what
is arguments only and it was very close
to for me but I end up going the other
way because for me Julia kind of uh it
was a deal-breaker for me when she said
that she herself would be the person
that would decide personal I've just we
are going through too much of fans
saying that they are going to do things
to their own specifications precedent
it's nothing personal but I don't I just
I don't I don't feel like that's the way
to go and so that little touch sort of
swayed me over to Emma sighs you over to
the side when this is I have to cast my
vote I don't know why he made an even
though I went the other way I did win
switch
around here it did not help my case at a
very close race
yes all right we are one one yet again
Danielle let the internet decide it all
right with 29 percent 70 percent it is
Avatar The Last Airbender 29 percent for
smash the chat you really you were
winning people over you know you were
having pre very passionate about smash
watch match as far as other things you
guys already know it's gonna be six
season in the movie I don't even have to
get into all of that I will say if you
go to Benji Hill durman's Twitter Benji
has photo shopped in our office cutout
of pita from The Hunger Games as the
third fighter so nothing to do for like
a year and a half and the one time we
can actually use it we don't think the
put event I would love the look yeah
what is he building minutes like our
resident artist oh yeah yeah what if
Josh Hutcherson won the whole hunterson
yeah alright so after three rounds it's
Emma - and Julia won and we're going to
the speed right the the first person to
four points wins the speed round again
works thusly I will ask the question
shout out your answers the first one I
hear we'll get to elaborate on their
answer first for 20 seconds the other
player will get 20 seconds and then in
the same order that you want ten-second
rebuttals y'all ready for this yeah
alright question one of the speed round
Will Smith is taking over from Robin
Williams role as the genie in Aladdin
who should take over his role in a 2019
version of mrs. Doubtfire uh I'm gonna
bill hater
that's a good bill hader you like that
Barry I love berries yeah I'm gonna go
josh brolin oh okay
hater versus Thanos a cable very ver
Stannis is pretty good assassin yes okay
we're fighting a hold of arguing right
now okay we heard Bill Hader first Emma
20 seconds on the clock
it starts ticking as soon as you speak
okay so what you need in a comedian
that's going to take over an iconic role
like mrs. Doubtfire is somebody that
really brings their own flavor to
everything they do and Bill Hader is
definitely one of those people he's an
incredible comedian we've also seen with
the show Barry what a wonderful range he
has as a dramatic actor as well and
that's something that mrs. Doubtfire is
it is both a funny movie but it has a
lot of heart to it as well and deals
with things like divorce and like
reconnecting with your kids okay Julia
Robin Williams was an actor from
Juilliard and so I think that very
similar Tammuz argument that there needs
to be a gravitas that is presented as a
performer for mrs. Doubtfire to balance
all the different tones and I seem like
Josh Brolin somebody that we should not
discount because he's somebody that has
a tremendous amount of rage and if you
follow him Instagram you know that these
are real goof and I think that he needs
the comedy that he deserves and he's
going to bring it because he's been so
thirsty for it and I think that on the
flip side of that Bill Hader is somebody
that really has been inhabiting the
comedy world and you need somebody that
already is in that space to dig into the
the darker sides of it that we do find
in a lot of comedy and Bill Hader would
also look right in the wing I think that
conversely to the same point that
somebody who hasn't been in the comedy
world is going to be giving it all that
they have because as we see with Barry
Bill Hader is tremendous but because
he's been at Barry he's been out of
documentary now so I think that time all
right Danielle Radford where do you come
down on this one I want to see both of
these movies so bad Julia I loved your
thing about him being a goof and winning
a comedy they're not gonna give him a
comedy I had to go with Emma's point
they're not gonna give him this comedy
for his first try I do want to see him
do more comedy but I got to go with Emma
yeah
yeah I mean I'll take your word for that
josh brolin is thirsty for the comedy
great choice
thank you so much and I would slap down
money to see that but I thought Emma had
there just a more convincing argument
that made a little bit more sense so
Emma you take that point and I throw and
had my vote but Emma you get that point
and you've to a game point type
situation here so Julie you need to take
this one to keep her going Emma you take
this you take the whole thing here we go
question number two the speed round
Christopher Nolan's new movie has a
title tenant better Nolan movie the
prestige or inception prestige I guess
inception okay Julie pretty enthused all
right we heard Emma first with Christine
so the prestige is a really intriguing
film about a couple of magicians and
also the drama that goes into that on
top of that you've got David Bowie
playing Nicola Tesla in it which really
is a high point of the film it is a
wonderful period piece it also is the
first of the sort of Christopher Nolan
films that really threw me for a loop
and and and surprised me with how the
ending went down Hugh Jackman gives a
fantastic performance along with well
I've never heard a conversation that's
talked about the prestige where people
don't say oh that's a great movie I feel
like if we're talking about what it
seeped into the pop-culture inception is
it how many times do we think about what
an inception is it's become a verb -
inception something is to have a story
within a story within a story to have a
thing within a thing within the thing it
is basically a living movie paradox and
I feel like people reference have more
in everyday life than they do The
Prestige exception is definitely
something that seems to never take a pop
culture due to the fact of course that
it was nominated for an Oscar now the
prestige again is this really it
surprised me in a way that I think
inception tried to do but didn't quite
achieve which is why I argue that it is
the theme is because thank you thank you
yeah Julia I I adore where you're coming
from here but her the point I go Emma
damn there's a certain University to
film that I think is relevant and it was
it was I'll give you the points for
creativity at least not making a run
away I'll vote for Julia right on right
on yeah there was Gavin there was good
stuff the comment from her Danielle yeah
these were both great I will say that
with Emma's argument it felt like it was
more just a list of things like it had
Bowie
it had magic it had drama whereas with
Julia's argument I felt like it was more
well-founded is weird to say that she
said dumb people feel smart I'm still
gonna get really angry I could do I can
show run [ __ ] alright save by the
dashcam question number three and it's
three to still game point for Emma what
actor would be the best possible choice
to play a terminator in an upcoming
sequel I'm gonna say it resolved ax okay
we gotta address Peter Dinklage Dinklage
okay - OH
- excellent misters Emma we heard you
first all right when it comes to a
terminator you want to bring somebody
that
brings that intimidation factor that you
could believe is truly a robot that is
sent to kill us all but at the same time
you kind of like it Idris Elba has got
all of that we were talking about the
sexiest man alive here people he is
charming he is handsome but if you came
face-to-face with him in a room you
would want to run immediately because
you know that he could absolutely kick
your butt but at the same time if he
turned and was like I think if we're
talking about acting chops and Peter
Dinklage in the same sentence and
nobody's arguing that this man doesn't
have acting chops I mean pretty much he
co handedly carried the finale of Game
of Thrones whether you liked it or not
he had the pivotal moments in that and I
also think that there's something to an
unsuspecting choice that is going to be
very pervasive in pop culture and I
think that nobody's going to forget
Peter Dinklage as the freakin Terminator
him coming out of it it's true it's a
very unexpected choice Peter English but
the thing is the Terminator the
Terminator is somebody that's gonna come
in and murder everybody it's in the name
they're not trying to be sneaky with the
Terminator and with eater selva you
definitely get an intimidating figure
yes but in your argument you said that
he had to be intimidating answer but
that I can I think the Peter Dinklage
has both he's going to kill coming in
and kill everybody but he's also going
to be somebody that you have tremendous
amount of sympathy for because that is
the way that he acts in Game of Thrones
when he won all right I think Julia
twisted in those words against her there
and the counter-argument I think she did
a pretty sneaky way much like Tyrion
Lannister so I'm gonna go with the dink
all right Julia and Peter Dinklage all
right one for Julian Dinklage Danielle
may I have to agree like all of those
interests does seem like he would be
such a like you would be such a great
figure but when you bring in what a
great actor is an unsuspected choice and
no one's gonna forget it and then that
at the end with the sympathy because of
such a great actor that Dinklage is and
the way that he played it in Game of
Thrones I've got a cope with you yeah
Julia you just tied this back alright
somehow someway you did alright it is
three three it all comes down to this
whoever gets this gets the game and let
me give you both big thumbs up this has
been a hell of a fun time watching you
guys clash so question number four of
the speed round the director of the new
child's play says he sees Chucky as a
tragic even sympathetic figure what
horror movie villain deep down is just
misunderstood misunderstood horror
villain hmm hi I'm gonna say go with
I'll just go Freddy Krueger you know
okay you got Freddy Krueger dumbest
dancer in the history of lay it on us
um the environment in the happenin Dan
get your mark walberg ready
all right we've heard Freddy Freddy
Kreuger first Emma you're going 20
seconds we'll start when you I mean I
think that even within the Nightmare on
Elm Street franchise they set up the
idea that Freddy is a little bit of a
misunderstood person he was born out of
a terrible violent sexual assault
situation with his mother and that he
was somebody that was never given a
chance because they automatically
assumed that because this kid was born a
bastard and out of something so violent
that he was always going to be awful
instead of giving him the chance to
nurture him was so terrifying about the
happening is that the villain was a
feature that was everywhere around us
there was no escaping from the
environment in the happening and the
thing that is terrifying and and
something that has misunderstood about
it is that climate change is real
climate change is real we've been taking
the climate for granted if we're going
on stuff that is real and terrifying
your dreams are real - and they're a
reflection of your subconscious and we
need to address the issue of mental
health which is really what nightmare
announced rate is all about because we
have Freddy Krueger who again is never
given a chance to be more than he is
because people make assumptions about
him we have 12 years left
[Laughter]
you know I I thought I thought Julia had
it
well after that first round that climate
change is real struck an important chord
and I love you just repeating that and
that's the volumes you know what may is
mental health awareness month climate
change you you just sounded that gong
for another important cause and you
brought it home and then you had more
points to back it up so oh just barely I
gotta go Emma
Danielle I got I don't even know how to
these were both so amazing yeah hell
yeah literally just because julia had
this nailed when she mentioned the real
world part and that the obviously
climate change is real and all of those
things the way that Emma fought back
Emma's fought back bringing it into
again meeting her where she was at and
bringing mental health stuff I've got to
go with Emma that was a really day very
Emma you just one movie funny
[Applause]
when the frickin earth you guys by the
time you watch this recycle and use
paper straws nicely done you guys we're
serious just that passion in your
arguments combined with your immense
like fandom and knowledge entertaining
as hell yeah you took you took that I
mean we're all winners for witnessing
we're all winners for for showing up and
doing it today yeah we started we're mom
and dad was telling us they were getting
a divorce yeah and then we still had a
birthday party at Chucky Cheese anyway
exactly and we got so many quarters to
play ball get one cuz in so many tickets
one cos you you know what and we even
had a bonding moment with mom's new
boyfriend please tell us where we can
find you give some shoutouts yeah oh man
well you know I can be found all over
the internet wherever Emma fights are
sold at my name Emma Fife find me over
at the Snowdown do it a bunch of stuff
there thank you to everybody that came
to our live event in Houston it was so
amazing it was so great to meet so many
of you it was really cool to like do
this mode on an actual wrestling arena
that felt really really good so yeah I
find me over on the patreon there and
just doing doing all kinds of stuff I'm
going to galaxies edge with Nerdist next
week
I think this galaxy well it already
started ten minutes ago Jedi Council
from Collider today check it out all
right click over there after this I'm
Julia I was at Disneyland alone
yesterday surrounded by teens because it
was grad night so you're living a
different life I'm actually impressed
got on all the things please listen to
my since is the podcast like a host with
Ali Kurtz evidence coming up Simpsons on
maximum fun if you live in the LA area I
host a monthly lecture series of lyric
Hyperion theatre next whatever Sunday
June 2nd it's going to be a writer's
assistant tell-all it's an industry
lecture series so we have people from
that are developing sex or show runners
or other people come and talk once a
month and I created a show called Tao
nice in COC in the Old West you can
watch it on black pills so go and try
and find it hopefully I don't know or
look at the trailer online awesome Julia
thanks so much let's go to the Dan cam
Dan Moreau so how will what what does
the weekend's box office look like it's
gonna be led yeah but it's a question
mark about how good it's gonna do
because the reviews are literally like
every time I look at that Rotten
Tomatoes that his at his wavered between
fresh and rot and it's like it's 60
percent 59 percent 60 percent disease so
I'll be curious to see if people like it
that's gonna be a big part of it really
the reviews are part of it but really
it's gonna be do people like it or do
they reject it so right I'm I'm gonna be
very anxiously just sort of why I don't
do it all weekend but I'll check in from
time to time to see how it's doing yeah
you push notifications turned on I'm
you're drinking coffee reformed Dan
Thank You Danielle Radford hello yeah
you can follow me on all the stuff that
Danielle Radford on Twitter Danielle
underscore Bradford on Instagram we just
put up a video that I myself and a bunch
of really talented people out here
worked on really hard
called the evolution of Captain America
so please watch that it deals with how
cap went from being a hero to the 40s
through his Emily
- now I think it's good people seem to
like it so go check it out very cool
check that out please check me out on
Twitter and Instagram as well at Hal
Rudnick and I have doing a lot of really
just ridiculous dumb stuff on Instagram
a lot of putting up a lot of dumb
characters doing weird movie reviews so
go to instagram at how rudnick check
that out I want to thank you guys for
just fighting the hell and a movie so
it's great stuff
Congrats and let's hang it by nose thank
you dance Thank You jte and Billy biz
and thank you for watching we'll see you
next time bye bye bye
you